ils ont ajouté des barrages routiers
pour l'occasion les fermiers indiens
souligner les quatre mois de leur lutte
contre la réforme agricole en périphérie
de la capitale delhi des milliers de
fermiers surtout des ciq du punjab ont
créé un véritable village de la
résistance les trois mois pour
libéraliser le monde agricole indiens
ont été adoptées en septembre mais leur
application suspendu pour le moment la
réponse viendrait éliminer le prix
plancher garanti pour une vingtaine de
d'arrêt c'est comme si le gouvernement
fédéral mette fin au régime de gestion
de l'offre au canada ce cultivateur de
blé vie tout campement depuis trois
semaines
ses camarades et lui sont inquiets pour
leur avenir et sa déchin langues et des
dieux mais le gouvernement et les
grandes corporations vont finir par nous
enlever nos terres dit il ils vont
contrôler le marché fixer les prix et
nous ne pourrons pu survivre
70% de la population indienne vit de
l'agriculture
une forte majorité de fermiers doivent
gagner leur vie avec de petits lopins de
terre de moins de deux hectares
surendettement détresse psychologique
hausse inquiétante des cas de suicide
les fermiers indiens peine déjà à
joindre les deux bouts lille a levé les
sens les pesticides dont l'utilisation
est très répandue l'irrigation
tout coûte extrêmement cher selon les
fermiers bon nombre d'entre eux doivent
parfois vivre des mois sans dégagé de
profits au gigantesque comment tout a
été pensé pour que les fermiers
poursuivre leur combat
les cuisine géante à aires ouvertes ont
été aménagés et on trouve aussi des
stations pour que les fermiers puissent
faire leur lavage des cliniques
médicales et même des bibliothèques ont
été aménagés élan de solidarité dans ce
pays où l'agriculture est au coeur de la
vie cette dentiste fille de fermiers et
venues pour la journée avec sa mère le
premier ministre mme odile accuse les
fermiers de mentir sur la réforme il
assure que les agriculteurs pourront
vendre autant qu'ils veulent à qui ils
veulent
il insiste sur le besoin de moderniser
cette industrie archaïque plusieurs
rondes de négociations entre des
représentants des fermiers et du
gouvernement ont eu lieu sans résultat
aucune autre rencontre n'est prévue
on ignore quand la réforme sera
finalement mise en application en effet
remis à eux sont déterminés à mener le
combat jusqu'au bout pour qu'elle soit
abandonnée ici philippe leblanc radio
canada new delhi